>> Steve Winick: Welcome.
My name is Steve Winick, and I'm
here at the Library of Congress,
where I am interviewing
Bobby McMillon
for the American
Folklife Center.
Bobby McMillon is,
among other things,
a recipient of the North
Carolina Folk Heritage Award.
He is a singer and a folklore
expert, and we're going
to be talking about
his life in folklore
in North Carolina and elsewhere.
So, Bobby, it's really
good to have you here.
Thanks for coming.
>> Bobby McMillon: It's
nice to be here today.
>> Steve Winick: So,
why don't we start
with you just telling
us a little bit
about where you're from?
>> Bobby McMillon: Well,
I was born in Lenoir,
North Carolina, in
Caldwell County.
My father grew up in the Cosby
section of east Tennessee,
just across the Smoky Mountain--
into the Smoky Mountains,
across the state line.
And, my mother grew
up in Mitchell
and Yancey Counties
in North Carolina.
And, through a series
of happenings,
they met in Lenoir,
my parents did.
And, I was born there.
And so, my father grew
up in the Smokies,
my mother in the
Blue Ridge, and then,
Lenoir was a furniture town.
And so, lots of people--
well, we had neighbors that
had been there for generations
in Caldwell County,
but we also--
there were people that came out
of northwestern North Carolina,
to work in the shops, we called
them, the furniture factories.
From east Tennessee as well
as [inaudible], those
counties there.
It was sort of like
a melting pot.
And, my mother's
parents, my grandmother
and grandfather Woodey [assumed
spelling] had a great influence
on my early life.
I was always close to them, and
my grandfather, he ran a store,
a grocery store, on
the Wilkesboro Road
between Lenoir and
the county line.
And, he had come there in '49.
One of his brother-in-laws
had worked
for the Broyhill family,
the furniture makers.
And, one of the brothers of the
owners of the furniture company
that run the sawmill end
of it, had a apple house
that he wanted my grandfather
to turn into a store.
And, that's how he wound
up in Caldwell County
from Mitchell County.
>> Steve Winick: Alright.
>> Bobby McMillon: And so,
I grew up around them a lot.
But, my grandfather kept
his home in the mountains.
He had-- well, he had two
houses up there, actually.
One that he built for
his oldest daughter.
They didn't live in it long.
But, the other one is the home
that my mother grew up in.
And, he kept them after
he went to Lenoir.
So, as a child, I would spend a
lot of time up there with them,
when they'd go [inaudible] home.
And, one of my mother's
two sisters married a man
in Yancey County,
across the river
from where my mother grew up,
and raised her family there.
And, I had three boy cousins
that I grew up around.
And, their daddy's mom and
dad used to tell us tales.
[laughs] They were both
born in the late 1800s,
and they had a lot
of stories to tell.
A lot of witch tales, and
haint tales, and booger tales.
>> Steve Winick: So, that
was your first experience
with stories, was [inaudible].
>> Bobby McMillon: With stories,
was listening to that family,
as well as my parents and my
aunts and uncles would tell
about things that
had happened to them.
They'd be bear tales, and
stories about mountain lions,
which in our part of the country
we always called painters rather
than panthers.
[laughs] And, usually
they were black painters.
And, they're still
being seen down there.
[laughs] Although
the word out on the--
from the Forest Service is
that there aren't any, but.
>> Steve Winick: But, the
stories are still there.
>> Bobby McMillon: The
And, my youngest brother just
saw one a couple of weeks ago.
[laughs]
>> Steve Winick: Yes?
>> Bobby McMillon:
On his property.
But anyway, that's
beside the point.
I loved to hear those
stories as a child.
And, when I was about--
well, from my father's side
there were a lot of stories
about blockading, or
moonshining, in east Tennessee,
the Cosby section, had one
of the biggest reputations
of making moonshine
of any of the areas.
I know every place like
Wilkes in North Carolina,
and different counties had their
famous spots for making liquor,
but Cosby was one of them.
And, that's where they
invented the submarine still.
>> Steve Winick: Alright.
>> Bobby McMillon: And, it
would only let a little bit
of the smoke out
from underground.
It was underground, you see.
And, if the moon was shining, it
would shine on that little puff
of smoke, and they called
it silver cloud liquor.
[laughs]
>> Steve Winick: Nice.
>> Bobby McMillon: So, I got
a lot of stories from them.
And, as I grew a little older,
I asked my grandfather--
at his home, he had a
Victrola talking machine,
and a lot of old records.
And, I would play those.
And, I asked him one time
who did he like the best
of those singers when he
was, you know, a younger man
and lived up there
in Mitchell County.
He said, well, he guessed
the Chuck Wagon Gang,
and the Carter Family
was about his favorite.
And so, since I was real close
to him, I began to pay attention
to what they were singing.
And, it really appealed
to me as well.
But, little bit after
that, I began to notice
that there were certain
songs in the community
that people were singing that
were similar to those records
that my grandfather had,
but some of them would
have different tunes,
and different verses.
Or, maybe more verses,
or even less.
And so, I got curious about it.
And, I loved to hear them sing.
And so, I began to
write down songs
that were known in my family.
My dad's oldest brother married
a girl in his home community
at Cosby, in Tennessee.
And, her mother, I always
knew her as Mamaw Phillips.
She was not a blood grandmother,
but she was my first cousin's.
But, I always knew her as Mamaw.
She was a singer, and she loved
for me to come and get her
to sing, and me to sing
with her too, sometime.
And, she taught me, at least 100
of the old songs that she grew
up with in the Smoky
Mountains in the early 1900s,
and well, throughout her life.
>> Steve Winick: So, you sing
some of those songs today?
>> Bobby McMillon: Some of
those songs I sing today.
When I was 16, my English
teacher at high school,
her family went to church
where my grandfather preached.
He was a Primitive
Baptist elder,
and I had grown up
in that church.
And, she knew that I liked old
music, and she had taken a class
at Appalachian under
Doctor Cratis Williams.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: And,
she thought that it would
be interesting if I met him.
And so, she made an appointment
and took me up there, to Boone.
And, I showed him what
I had written down.
And, he said, you know,
in order to document it,
he wrote it out in the book.
Showed me how to put down
who I'd learned from,
something about them
and their age.
And, he said someday
that'll mean more
to you than you think--
>> Steve Winick: Sure.
>> -- that it will.
And, I thought, well, you know,
that's just something I like.
I didn't really have any
ambition about getting
in public, or doing
anything like that more.
That it was just
interesting to me.
Of course, I never did feel
like I was a good singer,
but somebody had to learn them.
[laughs] And, I seemed
to be nominated
in that neck of the woods.
So, I just, I kept at it.
And, I would write down all the
songs that Mamaw Phillips and--
as it turned out, a woman that
we had-- her and her husband--
we had rented a home from them
when I was just about
3 years old.
She used to sing and play music.
And, after I got old
enough to know something
about the folk music, I found
out that she knew
the old ballads, too.
And, her family were
blockaders when she was a girl.
When the old folks made the
liquor up on the Brushy Mountain
in eastern Caldwell County,
her and her sisters would watch
out for the revenue men.
And, they'd pass the time of day
singing those old love songs.
>> Steve Winick: And,
what was her name?
>> Bobby McMillon: Aunt Lou
Brookshire [assumed spelling].
>> Steve Winick: Lou Brookshire.
>> Bobby McMillon: She was
a [inaudible] before she
ever married.
And, she taught me a
number of the old songs.
Some of them were folk songs.
Some of them were Child ballads.
And, she was a great
one to talk to.
Her brother, as a matter of
fact, had written some songs
about some murders in
the Caldwell County area,
and about one time an episode
of getting caught
for making liquor.
And, it was printed in the
North Carolina Folklore.
And, I told her about
that, and she said, What?
And, she told her
brother about it.
And, he wrote and told them that
he was the author of that song.
And, they sent him a copy
of the book that it was in.
>> Steve Winick:
Oh, that's great.
>> Bobby McMillon: But, anyway,
a few years after I'd met Doctor
Williams, or maybe a couple
of years, there was a senior
citizens' group in Lenoir
that invited him to come
and speak to their group.
And, he had another
appointment at that time,
and he referred them to me.
And so, that was the first time
I actually got up in public
and sang anything, you know.
>> Steve Winick: And, how
old you were [inaudible]?
>> Bobby McMillon:
I was about 18.
[laughs] And-- but, the odd
thing was once I got up there,
it didn't bother me to sing.
The people didn't-- it didn't
frighten me or anything.
It was preparing beforehand
that made me nervous.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: And so,
that started me singing once
in a while for a
group like that.
And then, about-- and, all this
time I was still learning songs
from a lot of the old people.
One of the-- Mister Broyhill,
his son operated the
sawmills they had
for the Broyhill people.
And, he loved old music.
And, one of his workers was
a man named Ralph Ellison
[assumed spelling].
And, they called him Smiley
because he didn't
have any teeth.
[laughs] And, he brought him
down to my grandpa's one time.
And, he had a banjo
there and a guitar.
And, he was playing some
Earl Scruggs something.
And, I asked him if he didn't
know any of the older songs.
And, he said, oh, you're wanting
something like Little Birdie.
And, I said, well, that'd work.
He pulled the finger picks off,
and went to playing
that the old way.
And then, I forgot just what
I asked him, but he said,
you mean you're wanting
something
like Lord Daniel, aren't you?
And, I said, yes,
that'd be fine.
And, he played Lord Daniel, and
The House Carpenter, and two
or three of them on the banjo.
And, that began a lifelong
acquaintance with his family.
His daddy was a, what Doctor
Williams called a mountain--
I can't think of the term.
A ballad rhymer.
He'd write ballads about
things that happened
up in Watauga County,
in the area near Meat
Camp, called Potterstown.
He was related to
all those people.
And, one of the songs that he
had written about his cousin,
Merchant Potter [assumed
spelling], who was killed
by [inaudible] Brown,
his cousin,
Uncle Bill Ellison [assumed
spelling] wrote the song,
and he give a copy of it
to his cousin, Jim Brown,
who added a verse to it.
Then, he gave it to a
[inaudible] man, who turned it
in to the Watauga
Democrat, which printed it
in the paper at Boone.
And then, that's how the Brown
Collection got ahold of that.
And, they printed it in the
North Carolina Folklore.
So-- but Uncle Bill Ellison,
if I could have known
him 20 years earlier,
I could have had a stack
of songs that thick.
He really knew, you know--
but he was toward
the end of his life,
and couldn't catch
his breath real well.
A lot of the old ballad
singers, they'd want you
to beg them to sing, anyway.
They'd say, oh, I
can't sing today.
I got a cold.
Or, you know, my throat's
real sore this morning.
Sort of like mine is now.
But, they really just
want you to keep onto them
until they'd sing for you.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: And so--
>> Steve Winick: So,
you got good at that.
Keep on asking-- and, yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes.
That's right.
And so-- and, he knew
a lot of the story--
the Potters were a pretty
wild bunch back in those days,
and a lot of killings had
happened in the family.
And, he knew the details,
and told me those.
Well, it was about '72 or three
that I had [inaudible]
Caldwell Community College,
and needed to work more than
I needed to go to school,
so I took me a job
at a wholesale grocery
store in Lenoir.
And, they had me
driving a truck.
And, I just got fed up
with doing it one day.
I just quit.
Don't know what struck me
that particular day
to quit, but I did.
And, that night, one of my
two best friends called me
and said my uncle, T.R.
Burne [assumed spelling]
who was the only obstetrician
in Wilkesboro at that time,
wants to go to Union
Grove, and said if you'd go,
he'd be on call, but he'd let
you drive his Corvette [laughs]
for the weekend.
And so, I said I
guess I could go.
And then, while I was down
there, I met a lot of people
that I would become
friends with over the years.
[inaudible] from Madison County,
and Betty Smith [assumed
spelling],
and there was a couple
there that was from Cosby
that caught my interest.
Their name was Jean and Lee
Shelton [assumed spelling].
And, they had a dulcimer shop.
And, they also ran the Folk
Festival of the Smokies.
And, they had a-- they were
selling recorders and dulcimers
at the-- it was at the
fiddler's grove section--
they'd already broken the
Fiddlers' Convention up.
And, [inaudible] ran
the Fiddlers' Grove.
And, I introduced myself
to them, and told them
that I knew a number
of songs that I learned
from Crosby, where they lived.
And, Jean was the daughter
of a famous bootlegger
from up there [inaudible].
He was still in prison
at the time I met her.
>> Steve Winick: Wow.
>> Bobby McMillon: Him and his
brother had robbed the Charlotte
mail train in the '30s, and
was put away for about ever.
But, anyway, she said that
if you'll come and join us
to prepare for our
folk festival on Cosby,
said I'll introduce
you to Janette Carter
of the old Carter Family.
And so, that's about all the
persuading I needed for that.
And, she was wanting to learn
some of the songs that I knew.
And so, while I was down
there, I met Janette Carter.
And, Janette invited me
to come to where she lived
in Maces Springs, Virginia and
see where her daddy was born.
We started a, well, the rest
of her life, I knew Janette.
I was with her when she first
started her music-making
down at her daddy's store.
Then they built the Fold up
there, the Carter Family Fold.
But, just a little
while after that,
my friend Cody Lowe
[assumed spelling],
whose uncle had invited
me to Union Grove,
because of my interest in old
music, he needed an elective,
and he was taking
[inaudible] at UNC.
So, he took Doctor Daniel
Patterson's folk song class.
And, he said, you ought
to come down here,
and go with me to class one day.
I said, well, I'd like to go to
see him anyway, because I'd go
in the library and
look at the books.
And, go to the Intimate
Bookshop, and Record Bar,
and have a good vacation
away from home.
So, I went and sat
in on his class.
And, when it was
over, he took me back
to meet Doctor Patterson.
And, he said, well, what's
some of the songs you know?
And, he told me later he was
expecting me to sing something
like May I Sleep in Your
Barn Tonight, Mister?
Or, some of the songs that were
popular, you know, in the '20s.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: Thirties,
maybe, from recordings.
And, I sang him a version
of Mellinger Henry [assumed
spelling] called it Home,
Dearie, Home.
It was a bawdy song that I'd
learned from Mamaw Phillips.
And then, I sang him
The House Carpenter.
And, his eyes started
getting bigger.
And, before the day was
over, we'd become friends.
[laughs] And, he took me to
[inaudible] and showed me the--
gave me a private showing
of John Cohen's film
of End of an Old Song.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon:
Is that right?
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
The Dillard Chandler film.
Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes.
And, I said, well,
wait a minute.
He said-- the word was out that
Dillard was dead, and I said,
no, I don't think he's dead.
I think he's still living.
But anyway, from-- one of Dan's
students was a boy named George
Holt, who became the first
director of the Folklife Office
at the North Carolina
Arts Council.
And, another student, I think,
[inaudible] say Allen Tullos,
who came to work
for the Smithsonian.
He was in that class.
I met him that day.
I think Kip Lornell was in
that-- I don't know why,
everything just fell together.
>> Steve Winick: So, you met a
lot of folklorists all at once.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes.
Yes. And so, it was
about a year later
that George Holt called
me, and wanted me to come
to the first Folklife
festival they had at Durham.
And then, I went
to the second one.
I think it was at
[inaudible], maybe.
No. I'm not sure.
But, anyway, it was just
a couple of years later
until Allen called on me, and
scouted me and a bunch of them
from Madison County to go
to the Smithsonian
for the bicentennial.
And, in a lot of words,
that's sort of what, you know,
got me started in this.
Through George's efforts,
I applied for the
visiting artist program
and the artist in
residence program.
And, I worked in
the schools trying
to awaken the children's
awareness of their own culture
and what their parents
might [inaudible] at home.
And then, I worked in
the community colleges
for four or five years.
And, that was just a little
summary of my-- [laughs]
>> Steve Winick: Well, I think
some of the interesting things
that you mentioned, one,
the fact that you got
into the songs a little bit
though first hearing some
of those old records,
and recognizing
that in your community,
there were songs
that were similar to those.
And, I think, that's a way that
a lot of people who aren't part
of your community get
interested in those songs, too.
And then, they go
looking for them.
>> Bobby McMillon: You know,
I thought when I was a child
that songs were composed
to be recorded.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: And, that's
what threw me off for a time.
And then, by accident,
when I was about 14 or 15,
I was in the library and came
across the Frank
Brown collection
of North Carolina Folklore,
and I saw all these songs
that I was hearing
in the country,
and they were different
versions.
And, some of them were
longer, and shorter.
And, that answered my question.
And, from that point
on, I was hooked.
But, the best part of all of it
was getting to know the people,
and sitting on their
porches and talking to them.
And, listening at them sing.
One of my third cousins
taught me the first
of the old Child ballads
that I ever heard.
Fair Ellinor and the Brown Girl.
I was at his house.
My daddy had bought
me a tape recorder,
and his wife was singing
some songs that she knew
from the '20s and '30s, and
he was shaving in the house.
About that time I heard
something about lords
and ladies, and I said,
Nate [assumed spelling],
where did you learn that?
He said, Pap sang it for me.
And, he knew the
whole ballad of it.
It was like that you
could-- from that point on,
it was always like it
brought the past to real life.
It was like I could go down the
road, and go around the bend,
and see somebody on
a milk-white steed,
or a castle sitting there.
And, I mean, these people
that were singing them,
had no connection
with the old country.
But yet, they were
singing what had come
by word of mouth to them.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
That was the connection.
Yes. Yes. So, I mean, but
that also opens an interesting
question, which is, within the
community, there were all kinds
of different songs, including
those really old ones
that had references
to Britain and Europe,
and steeds and castles.
But then, other things
like Tom Dooley.
And then, the ones that even you
met the people who wrote them.
Were you aware that there
were different kinds
of songs like that originally?
Or, did it-- was that
something you gradually learned?
>> Bobby McMillon: Well, see
everybody that sang back then,
they might sing Barbara
Allen, and then turn around
and sing George Jones's
The Window Up Above.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: And so,
I just realized it was
just what they had learned.
And, as I began to look
more into the, like,
into the Brown Collection
and others--
Cecil Sharp, I soon
discovered him,
and knew how he went about it.
I knew that there were
different versions.
I mean, there were
the American songs,
as well as the European songs.
And, it was all just
a part of it.
They didn't differentiate.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: Between one.
And, another thing, one of my--
when I went to school as a boy,
I lived not far from
the Wilkes County line.
And, a number of my
playmates in school,
and some of the older
people that I knew
in the community was related
to the characters from--
that were related to Tom Dooley.
And then, my grandmother told
me the story of Frankie Silvers,
who was hanged for cutting
her husband's, I mean,
chopping his body up one night.
And, she was the only woman
that, to my knowledge,
that was ever legally
hanged in North Carolina.
And then, from a great-aunt
of mine, I learned the tune
from it, and then Lou
Brookshire that I knew
in Caldwell County
knew a different tune,
but she knew the same words.
And--
>> Steve Winick: And, that was
Frankie and Charlie Silver?
Do you have a family
connection to them?
I thought I read somewhere--
>> Bobby McMillon: Charles
Silver's daddy was the brother
to my great-great-great-great-
grandfather.
>> Steve Winick: Alright.
>> Bobby McMillon: And, only
in the last couple of years,
I knew that Charles' mother
died when he was born,
and his daddy married and
had a big family after that.
But, his mother was
my grandmother's
great-grandfather's
great-grandmother's sister.
>> Steve Winick: OK.
>> Bobby McMillon: So,
I was kin to Charles
through my grandmother
and my grandfather.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: And-- but,
I heard the story as a child.
My grandmother didn't
know that connection.
I just dug it out, you know,
looking through genealogy,
and finding out the
facts of the case.
But, I could see that from
my grandfather's house
in Mitchell County, I could
look out the back window,
and see where the ranch
ran into the river,
where Frankie was supposed to
have walked, and punched holes
in the ice to make people think
that her husband
had fallen through.
Then up the road a little
ways were some rocks
where she was supposed to have
hidden his lights, the lungs,
and the guts, and parts that
don't burn easily, under a rock.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: But--
>> Steve Winick: Well,
that'll get you believing
in the haint stories,
too, right?
>> Bobby McMillon:
Oh, I was afraid to go
out of doors [inaudible].
We didn't have a
bathroom in the house.
And so, at night, until bedtime,
you had to go off the porch.
And, I was afraid to go outside,
because I thought I'd see her
spirit coming around the road
with red eyes, and a
bloody axe in her hand.
[laughs]
>> Steve Winick: So, that was
part of the story they told?
That is scary.
And, I guess that's the song
that you're mostly
associated with.
Partly because of Dan
Patterson's book that was
about you and your
connection to [inaudible].
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes.
He was interested in my
version of the story,
and dug all of that out.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon:
Put that together.
>> Steve Winick: So, another
thing that you've done,
you've talked about it a little
bit, is your own collecting.
You've visited with
people, with--
I mean, you've done all the
work that we're doing here.
Oral histories, and
folklore collection.
What was that like, begin a
community member who also went
out with a tape recorder
[inaudible]?
>> Bobby McMillon: It was fun.
[laughs] Up until I was in about
the 11th grade in high school,
my dad went and bought me
a small handheld RCA tape
recorder, would hold
a 5-inch reel.
Would run either by
electricity or batteries.
But, up until then,
I just learned them
like everybody else did.
>> Steve Winick: Sure.
>> Bobby McMillon:
By hearing them,
and trying to remember
the tunes.
And, I would write
down the words.
Well, then I got that, and then,
I would get them
to sing the tunes.
And then, a lot of the
stories, like my great uncle,
my mother's brother-in-law's
father,
that told me the old
haint tales and stuff,
I knew he'd be self-conscious
if he knew I was recording him.
And, in his house, he
had a big coal stove
in the middle of
the living room.
And, his chair was over yonder
on the other side of it,
and he'd sit and smoke his pipe.
And, there was a couch on
this side of the stove.
So, I would sit facing him,
and I'd have my tape recorder
beside me, and I'd turn it on
and record him telling
all those old--
he had some great old stories,
about things that happened
in the Caldwell County,
Tennessee, Mitchell County,
North Carolina, area in
the 1800s, and 1900s.
And, those old ghost stories.
And, what I would do, I
knew that it'd be obvious
that I had something in my hand.
I'd record a couple of Carter
Family songs when I'd go in,
and I'd play the
Carter Family music,
because I knew they'd love that.
And, they did.
And then, when I turned that
off, I'd just turn it on
and let it records
while I talked to him.
>> Steve Winick: See, we
wouldn't be able to do that,
but when it's your own family--
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes.
Yes.
>> Steve Winick:
You take liberties.
Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: I
seldom ever done it.
When I was getting
music, only one time,
Aunt Lou Brookshire one time,
she wasn't quite ready to sing
or something, or she didn't
quite have the tune set
in her mind, and she
said, you've got that on,
and wanted me to turn
it off for a minute.
But then, after she got going,
she let me turn it back on.
>> Steve Winick:
She was OK with it?
Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes,
but most of the people,
when I was recording the
songs, that didn't bother them.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: To run it.
And, you know, I didn't--
It was always such a personal
thing, I really didn't--
you know, in books I might have
been a little more academic,
because I was looking to find
out where all this came from.
But, as far as actually
going out and hearing it,
and singing it, and sharing
songs with the people,
it was like I was more of
a family-type atmosphere.
And so, I had to
distinguish that.
I got to thinking one
day that it was odd
that in Caldwell County I knew
the story Tom Dooley well.
And, Cliff Broyhill
that introduced me
to the Ellison family, also
introduced me to an old man
who was born in the 1880s,
who was the grandson of one
of the Dooley women that
lived in Tom Dooley's days,
and he knew a version
of it that wasn't
like the Kingston Trio's at all.
And, he told me the whole story.
And-- but also, the
songs that I learnt--
the families that I knew
real well, the Potters,
all lived on the border of
the Ashe and Watauga County.
And, my mother's people
lived from the southern part
of Avery County all through
Mitchell and Yancey County.
And then, I became just,
almost a member of the family
of the Wallins [assumed
spelling]
over in Sodom, in
Madison County.
And, knew them, well, from
back in those days until now.
And then, my daddy grew up
one county from Madison,
the next door county
in Tennessee.
And so, I was really lucky.
And then, also, my
father growing
up in the Primitive Baptist
church, they always sang
from the shape notes,
hymnals after they had books
that had the notes in.
And, I noticed early on
that many of the tunes was
in a real similar style to
the way they sang at church.
They were often in a minor
key, and when anybody was--
not many of the people
could read the notes,
although they had
singing schools.
But, the style would be very
similar to the ballad singing.
>> Steve Winick: And, did people
ever sing those church songs
at home as well?
Like, sing some of
the religious songs?
>> Bobby McMillon: Right.
Mamaw Phillips who grew up there
on Cosby, she taught me a number
of the songs that she
learned growing up.
She'd sing-- one was
called The Old Churchyard.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon:
An old, old song.
And, I always loved
that because it had
such a haunting tune to it.
And then, when she was a
young girl, she would go
to [inaudible] meeting,
they had other kind
of Baptist churches
over there too.
And, Methodist, and you know.
And, she taught me one.
[singing] I do believe without
a doubt Christians has a right
to shout.
I'm happy.
Oh, my the Lord continue
with me.
And, she learned those
at [inaudible] meetings.
And When the Last
Trumpet Shall Sound.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: They
were all lumped together,
the meeting house songs
as she called them.
And, they always
called them love songs,
everywhere that I lived
and went to up in there.
They were always,
always love songs,
unless they were religious.
And then, they were
called meeting house songs.
>> Steve Winick: So, the
old ballads, as well as the,
sort of, Tom Dooley-style
ballads, those were all,
kind of, called love songs?
>> Bobby McMillon: They
were love songs, right?
Well, if you had them
written down, now,
then they were called ballads.
>> Steve Winick: Ballads.
Right.
>> Bobby McMillon:
Or, song ballads.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: But,
church house songs,
or meeting house songs were the
only differentiation they had
between the two.
But, Tom Dooley was a love song
was just like The Great Titanic.
>> Steve Winick: Yes, yes.
Or Fair Ellindor.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes, right.
>> Steve Winick: Alright.
So, let's talk a little
about the North Carolina
Heritage Award.
How'd you find out that
they'd selected you for that?
>> Bobby McMillon:
That was in, I guess,
you're asking me something now.
My short-term memory
[inaudible] used to be.
I can tell you hundreds
of songs,
but trying to remember what
happened on certain times.
Yes, in 2000, through
an acquaintance
with Sheila Kay Adams,
a man from New York named Jerry
Epstein had me to go to England.
He made appointments
at different folk clubs
for a month over there.
And so, I got to go to
England, and Wales, and Ireland.
And, later that year,
they called me.
I don't know who.
It might have been
Wayne Martin, who is--
well, he's over the
Arts Council now,
rather than the Folklife
Center, I guess.
I believe he's the
one that called
and told me they had picked
me to be one of the recipients
of the North Carolina
Folk Heritage Award.
And, he said, by the way,
you'll also be the youngest
that we've ever selected.
I said, you thought I was
going to die, didn't you?
[laughs] Wanted to give it to
me before I kicked the bucket.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon: But, I think
it was Wayne that called me
and told me about that.
>> Steve Winick: Great.
>> Bobby McMillon: That
was really enjoyable.
It's funny, that was
a really good year.
I got that award, got to
go to England, and then,
a woman named Sara
Grey was in charge
of the Pinewood-- what's it?
The Pinewoods--
>> Steve Winick:
Pinewoods folk music camp.
>> Bobby McMillon: Camp, yes,
at Plymouth, Massachusetts.
And, they were having bunches
over from England and Ireland.
And, she invited me and
my sister-in-law to go up,
and be there that week.
So, it was real eventful year.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
Sounds great.
One other thing to ask about.
We did mention your
connection to Daniel Patterson,
Doctor Patterson, but he's
also-- he wrote a book,
essentially about you,
and about your connection
to the Frankie Silver ballad.
So, how did that develop?
How did you get to be so close,
and to talk to him
so much about that?
>> Bobby McMillon: Well,
Doctor Patterson and I,
after our first meeting,
I always stayed in touch.
And, he would have me come
occasionally for his classes.
He would get little
grants to have me come
and do some work for UNC.
And, of course, he was in
connection with Wayne Martin
and George Holt,
and all of those.
And that was one of the first
songs that I had ever sung
for him, and told him
that story, maybe at one
of his classes, I guess it was.
And, he used to have
home parties sometimes,
and I'd come to that.
And, he began to think that
that might make a good premise
for a book.
And, I told him, my
mother told me a story.
I never heard it when I was real
little, but my mother told me
that she said, you know up
there where Frankie's cabin was,
after the old cabin fell in,
there was another one built
where the fireplace was.
And, it had begun to fall
in by the time I came along.
And, Momma said that one time
we were all-- went for a walk,
and just walked up the holler
where that had happened,
and she said that there
was-- I can't remember now--
might have been a
crabapple tree.
There was a tree
that grew up there.
And, she said she always
heard that if you got into it,
you couldn't get
out without help.
And, she said-- I must have been
about two or three year old--
she said, sure enough I
went right up to that tree,
and I couldn't get
out to save my life.
I probably got tangled
up in it, I don't know.
But, she had to get me out.
And, Dan thought that that would
make a great title for the book,
so he called it A Tree
Accurst: Bobby McMillon
and stories of Frankie Silver.
And, my grandmother's uncle,
Ladd Hughes [assumed spelling]
told the story a little
different than most everybody
around there ever had.
He said that her
father, Frankie's father,
ate supper with them, the
night Charlie got killed.
And, when he got done eating,
he said, I think I'll lay down.
And, she told him
she'd laid a sheepskin
in front of the fireplace.
Thought he'd want to play with
the baby until he got sleepy.
And, when he went to
sleep, her daddy said,
now's your time, Frankie.
Now's your time.
And so, she went
and got the axe.
She'd done sharpened it.
I'd forgot, through
cutting up the wood.
And, she'd rare back
at him, to hit him.
He was laying on his back.
Said every time she would,
he'd smile at her in his sleep.
>> Steve Winick: Wow.
>> Bobby McMillon: And, she
done that about three times.
And, every time she'd give
up and wouldn't do it.
She said, I can't kill him, Dad.
Said, he's smiling
at me in his sleep.
And, her daddy said if you
don't kill him, I'll kill you.
And, finally he talked her
into taking a whack at him.
And, she give him one
lick to the head, and run
and jumped in the bed.
And, her daddy, they said
that he cut his head off
with such force, that the
head bounced to the rafters
and blood went everywhere.
But, he chopped him up, and
done the rest [inaudible] put
on his boots, went
down to the river.
And, that was never in any of
the official stories about that.
But, Charles's father, who
lived in the old log cabin,
which is still there,
by the way,
and still able to be lived in.
It's like, the best log
house he was ever in.
When I was a kid,
the man, the Silvers,
that had [inaudible] it,
his wife was my grandmother's
first cousin.
And, Will Silvers told
my grandfather Woodey
that he believed that the reason
that Charles was killed was
that her people wanted
to go West.
And, that they needed
Charles to get his daddy
to give him his portion of the
property so they could turn it
into traveling goods you know.
People thinks in old age
they just hopped on a horse,
or took off walking,
or something.
But, everything had to
be provisioned back then.
>> Steve Winick: Sure.
>> Bobby McMillon:
Just like now.
>> Steve Winick: It was worse.
You couldn't stop
for-- at a store.
>> Bobby McMillon: That's right.
That's right.
And, Charles wouldn't do it.
He just wouldn't do it.
And, they said that it was
through anger over that
that he was-- believed that
that's what killed him, Charles.
>> Steve Winick: Interesting.
>> Bobby McMillon: But, she
wouldn't tell on her daddy.
>> Steve Winick: Yes.
>> Bobby McMillon: And
so, she was hanged.
>> Steve Winick: That's
a whole other story
from what the song
usually tells.
>> Bobby McMillon: Right.
She made a confession, but
the confession was lost.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> Bobby McMillon:
That she made.
And then, on the scaffold,
she started to speak,
but her father was in
the crowd, and said,
Die with it in you, Frankie.
Die with it in you.
She wouldn't tell.
>> Steve Winick: So, are you
going to sing that ballad
for us later when
we do the concert?
>> Bobby McMillon:
I probably will.
>> Steve Winick: Alright.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes.
If I've got any voice left.
[laughs]
>> Steve Winick: Sounds good.
Well, we will let
you rest your voice.
>> Bobby McMillon: [inaudible]
>> Steve Winick: And,
we will just thank you
for this wonderful interview,
and for telling us some
of your stories,
and your own story.
The story of your own life.
>> Bobby McMillon:
Well, thank you.
I appreciate you.
>> Steve Winick: Thank you
so much, Bobby McMillon.
>> Bobby McMillon: Yes, sir.
Thanks.